Okay, so I want to pick up in August the 12th, 1918, the predominant passion of
Louisa that Jesus free her from the bother that he has put on her. Now you
wouldn't expect that this would come back in volume 12, but it has, because in
volumes one to four, Louisa was annoying Jesus all the time by saying, "I don't
need the priest to come. Can you just give rid of the priest?" She didn't say it
as awfully as that. You know what I mean? What I mean? She was telling him, "Shouldn't
want the priest." We're back to it. Before I even start this, I want to give you
Isaiah 55, 8-9. Isaiah 55, 8-9 says, "My thoughts are not your thoughts. My
ways are not your ways. My ways are as different from yours as the heavens are
from the earth." And it's just difficult for us to realize that the Lord just
doesn't think the way we do. So continuing my usual state, Louisa said, "I was
thinking to myself that if the Lord wanted a certain thing from me, he should give
me a sign." Now I would have thought that at this stage for her she would have
been beyond signs. Okay, when you're very early in the spiritual life you want to
sign. It sort of says, "If this is right, you do to this." Remember Gideon in the
book of Judges? Yeah, you put the Jew on the fleece and then I'll know that it's
you. And when you got the Jew on the fleece, he said, "Well, you wouldn't mind doing it
the opposite way and then I'll be sure." That's called unbelief. Okay. So you don't
expect it to be looking for a sign at this particular point. So he should give me
a sign. And the sign would be that it was a freeing me from the coming of the
priest. I say, "Oh, no. We're not back to this again." I'm sure you've had
experiences in home life of saying, "No, this subject isn't coming back again, is it?"
And blessed Jesus made himself seen in my interior. Now notice it's in his
her interior. He's not coming out. With a ball in his hand, as though in the act of
throwing it on the ground. And then he told me, "My daughter, this is your
predominant passion. It's the thing you keep going back to." Now one of the best
things to get rid of in Lent, if you can, is the predominant passion. The others
are easier to deal with. That I free you from the bother. Now notice
bother is just annoying her. But do you remember Paul said he had a thorn in his
side? Well, this is hers. He said, "I keep you in this state for the whole world."
Now notice the for and ring that. That's the important word. You're not in this
for yourself. You're not in this for some kind of personal perfection for
yourself. This is something I'm doing for the whole world. Everybody has to
benefit from this. And I use you as not to send the world to ruin completely. Now
Louisa has heard that time out of number, which we find it very difficult to take
on board, that my reactions have such a consequence. So in other words she's in
this bed going through this experience for the church and for the world. And she's
already been told eloquently that the church is like a building that's
leaning on her. While this other thing with which you could do good is a small
part. He said in other words, the thing that's irritating you is something small.
But that's the way it is with us isn't it? It can be something quite small that
really irritates us. And we find it intolerable. So Louisa said, "My Jesus, I'm
unable to understand this." We get that one. "You keep me without suffering." Now
there she has held on to her old idea of suffering. She tells us that every
single message she's going through hell because of the privation. But apparently
that isn't suffering. See what I mean? In other words, when we're looking at
ourselves, we can't see the word for the trees. That's the reason why it's good to
have somebody outside to reflect something to you. When she says, "You leave me
without suffering." In other words, she's not being crucified as she was in
volumes one to four. Okay? Jesus began to change her and she hasn't really grasped
that everything is now on a divine level. Okay? It seems that you keep me
suspended from the state of victim. And then you tell me that you use me in
order to send, not to send the world completely to ruin. And Jesus said, "Yes,
it is false that you don't suffer." Of course it's false. She's going through hell
when she doesn't see him. "At the most you do not suffer such pains as to be able
to disarm me completely." But if sometimes you remain suspended, your part, your
will is not in it. Now if her will was in it, then the disasters on the world would
be so much greater. Because it seems to me, I could be wrong, ladies are now allowed
to be infallible, which is great. It seems to me that the two people who upheld
the 20th century were Padre Pio and Louisa. Now there were other victim souls as
well, but they seem to have been the two big ones. And so Jesus said that if he
suspends her, her will isn't in it, so it's okay. But here your will would enter.
She wants to get rid of this irritation. You cannot understand the sweet
violence you do to me with your waiting. Now that's Matthew 11, 12. The Kingdom of
God suffers violence and the violent take it by force. Now also the value of
waiting upon the Lord, the famous one, is Isaiah 40 31. Isaiah 40 31. Those who
wait upon the Lord shall renew their strength. They shall mount up with wings
like the eagle. They shall run and not be weary. They shall walk and not faint. So
Louisa doesn't grasp the enormity of the thing that's going on that when she
waits in agony for the Lord to come back. So feeling suspended, not seeing me as
you're used to and remaining in the same place. That means doing your work of
intercession as before without moving anything. He said that's what does it?
You remain faithful. And besides I want to be free over you whenever I please. I
will keep you suspended and when I don't I will keep you bound. I want you at the
mercy of my will. That is the hardest thing for us. Because no matter what you
say to the Lord about I give myself to you, I consecrate myself to you. We want a
little bit of control still. We find it extremely difficult to feel I am not
calling the shots. I mean I've often said to people that one of the reasons why I
hate traveling in airplanes is that I have no control over what happens. You're
sitting there at the mercy of somebody in the front. I remember one very
difficult airplane ride that I took to Glasgow in very bad weather and there's
crosswinds just at the point where the plane goes over the Irish Sea. I went
so white that the air hostess said to me would you like to talk to the two lads?
I said I'm like good. I was bad enough until then but now I was in a
proper tizzy and I don't know what made me say yes. So I said yes. Those were the
days when they'd allow you talk to the pilots. So I went off and I saw these two
young men in the cockpit and one of them turned around and he said what's your
problem? And I said I had a problem before I came to the cockpit I said now I
have two and instinctively he laughed. He said what's your second one? I said my
life is in the hands of two teenagers and he said woman he said you've made my
day. I'm just fascinating just what was happening. And you see it's this problem
that you've somebody else is in control. There's nothing you can do about it. We
find this difficult and if we find it difficult in something like an airplane
how difficult is it in your prayer life where it's entirely you and it's your
interior and we have this scary thing that well maybe I could be deceived maybe
I'm going in the wrong direction. You know maybe Satan has got a hook into me
we've got all kinds of fears about it. So the fact that Jesus wants us at the
mercy of his will is very very very difficult for us. He said and I wanted
without your will. In other words you let the two teenagers drive the
aircraft and you don't interfere. I remember when we landed in Glasgow I got
the biggest wave and a kiss blown in the air from the cockpit of the two teenagers.
I'm sure they were in the middle 30s you know and so he said to Louisa if you are
content with this he said you can do it otherwise no. In other words Louisa I
need your surrender. So I said to my two teenage pilots in inverted commas I said
the fact that I'm walking back to my seat I said it's an incredible grace
because I had to surrender to this thing the bad weather plus the youth that was
up manning the now that I could have done anything you know what I mean but
the fact that you couldn't do anything doesn't mean you're gonna let somebody
else do it that's the amazing thing with us we're very logical you know some of
us and what Jesus said it's not going to work without your surrender it's that
simple. Another day I was feeling ill Louisa said with the continuous throwing
up that I do and I was saying to Jesus what would you miss I love the way she
approaches him by giving me the grace of not feeling the necessity for food in
other words instead of all this mess that's going on every day could you just
take away my need for food you see logic on our side okay to the point she said
well I'm forced to throw it up and she said I'm only saying this to obey in
other words the idea has come from the priest and Jesus said my daughter what
are you saying quiet he said don't say this anymore you must know that if you
had no need of anything I would let the people die of starvation she cannot
grasp the importance of what's happening in her that it's out there having an
effect on the whole of humanity I would understand that but because you need it
since it can serve your necessities I for love of you and because of you give
the necessary things to others look at that because you have this needs and I
reach out to your needs I therefore reach out to the needs of others again
Louisa wouldn't know that she was tied that closely to history and to the rest
of humanity on the other hand by taking food and then bringing it up you do good
to others and your suffering glorifies me even more how many times while you
throw up I see you suffering and since you suffer in my will that's the bit you
underlying she's not just suffering in the body you're suffering in my will I
take that suffering of yours I multiply it and I divide it for the good of
creatures in other words he's saying to her that no matter what happens for you
the rest of humanity is actually benefiting and I enjoy it and I say when
he says I enjoy he says I'm happy with it and I say to myself this is the bread
of my daughter which I give for the good of my children so I want to give you
Isaiah 40 verses 13 and 14 Isaiah 40 verses 13 and 14 I want to give you Sam
139 verses 17 and 18 and I want to give you Romans 11 verses 33 to 36
now the bread that Luisa is giving to the Lord to give to other people is the
sacrifice sacrificing of her own will and the surrender of her own will locked
into the divine will that gives the God the freedom to do great things upon the
earth there's another way we can live a very important Lent and never mind the
virus chocolate this is much more important that your will locked into his
will allows him to do something incredible for this planet if we could
give him that in Lent he wouldn't worry about anything else I don't think we
would either so August the 19th 1918 Jesus is tired of the vile deeds of
priests as I was in my usual state my beloved Jesus made himself seen in my
interior as though within a circle of light because God is light to see one
John one five and he told me let's see what good have we done today notice the
we you and I are one and he looked and he looked I believe that that circle of
life was his most holy will and that since I had united myself to his most
holy will in other words I had fused myself this is why he was saying this
and he added anyway I am tired of the vile deeds of priests I can take no more
I would want to have done with it or how many devastated souls how many of them
disfigured how many idolatized now idolatized means that the worship has
gone from God to something else whatever the something else is to use holy things
in order to offend me he said this is the most bitter pain this is the most
excurable sin it is the mark of total ruin I a lost soul which draws the
greatest maladictions and breaks any communication between heaven and earth
I find that very frightening I don't know about you but he's not saying whether
it is the abuse of the liturgy or the abuse of children or the abuse of
whatever I would want to eradicate these things from the earth he said that's
Revelation 11 18 Revelation 11 18 I will destroy the destroyers of the earth
chastisement will come and they will multiply death will devastate cities many
houses and roads will disappear there will be no one to live in them mourning
and desolation will rain everywhere I don't know if you get the message in the
last message whatever Louisa did in the divine will affected the whole human
race whatever sins these priests are committing is bringing devastation upon
the earth look at the effect we have so I want to give you Matthew 23 the whole
of it which is Jesus's indictment of the religious leaders of his own day you
know when I read something like that I just thank God I'm a nobody I thank God
I'm just such a little one that you can just live in you're nothing this how
terrifying it is to have any office in the church or in the world because Satan
can pull you down dreadfully and you don't even know you're being pulled you
don't he blinds your eyes and everything so you don't realize the import of what
you're doing so it is extremely important for us to keep all the leaders of the
church and state in prayer and intercession it's terribly important and it's not
just a nice thing to do it's actually essential for them and so Louisa said I
prayed and prayed again and having remained with me for a good part of the
night he was so much in suffering that I felt my heartbreak and pain so he was
saying this is a major problem and this is only 1918 that's was scary September
the 4th 1918 again you have the laments of Jesus because of priests as I was in
my usual state Jesus told me my daughter creatures want to challenge my
justice they don't want to surrender do you see the problem and do you see why
he keeps asking those of us who want to live in the divine will that we
would surrender and surrender more and if possible surrender completely so I
want to give you a mike six eight this is all the Lord asks if you only this
that you would act justly that you would love tenderly and you would walk humbly
with your God he didn't ask much but we do everything except that that's mike
a six eight and it's considered by the scholars as a summary of the teaching of
all the prophets he said they don't want to surrender in other words they don't
want to do my will and therefore my justice does its course against the
creature so remembering some of the earlier messages today that they are now
brushing up against that electric fence okay they're brushing up against justice
and these people are from all classes high in law accepting not even those who
are said to be my ministers maybe these even more so he he delicately got to the
point of saying the priests are sometimes worse now why would the priests be
worse if you know the teaching of the Old Testament I think it's a great draw
back that Catholics have not studied the Old Testament in detail because if you
have you'd get messages like this if the Lord chooses somebody that means that
that head has been raised above the paraphern prime target for say whether
it's an individual whether it's a group whether it's a nation and it's the very
fact that that person has been called that they become a prime target for
Satan and so while they have enormous privilege and enormous grace offered to
them Satan does his damnedest to destroy them now in pulling down the priest the
Satan is actually trying to destroy the church in trying to destroy the church
Satan is trying to destroy everything that Jesus gave his life for and so we've
got to wake up and realize what's actually going on and what is behind
things so that we stop putting all the blame on this particular individual who
fell if I can put it that way and realize that we've got going to huge
intercession for the protection of the church and further protection of the
harvest of Jesus in the world that makes sense and otherwise we'd start
isolating this into one particular group you know what I mean if you look at the
world today parents are being targeted wonder why because they are upholding
family to the world priests are being targeted they are upholding the church
teachers are being targeted they are upholding the education of children for
the next generation it's anybody who raises the head about the paraphernical
even doctors are being forced to kill children instead of healing them so if
you see it in terms of Satan attacking the church it'll make more sense
than looking at the individuals is that any help so Jesus says what poison they
have now that poison has been put in by an enemy and they poison those who
approach them instead of placing me in souls they want to place themselves they
want to be surrounded to be known and I remain aside their poisonous contact
instead of recollecting souls distracts them from me instead of rendering them
withdrawn into their nothingness as we would understand they render them more
free and more faulty more liberal we would say and faulty so much so and that
one can see souls who have no contact with them being more good and even though
they're more withdrawn from the church what he's saying here is sometimes when
a priest has gone bad the little group of laypeople who are absolutely leaning on
them for everything can be poisoned more than someone who isn't going to church
on a Sunday and isn't involved in this that's the amazing thing okay and a little
thought has just come into my head and I know it didn't come from me and that is
to remind you that this is 1918 and so the infiltration of the clergy by the
Freemasons the calm the communists first then the Freemasons and then the
liberati what what you call luminati to hear me liberati I'm getting old the
illuminatic and the communists paid atheists to go into the seminaries and
paid them very well but these men at no grace so how do they survive six years
in the seminary they brought in homosexuality and this homosexuality is
what has corrupted the the clergy which you need to know it was put in it was
brought in by the enemy and brought in by people whose whose deliberate intention
was to bring down the church because the communists at the time said that they
the structure of the church was so perfect that it had to be destroyed from
within on its own ministers could destroy it so this is why you have Jesus
lamenting about the clergy because and he's not telling Louisa Louisa couldn't
have coped with what was actually going on and but Taylor Marshall has written a
book on the infiltration of the church now and so Jesus said so I cannot trust
anyone I'm forced to allow that the people go far away from the churches in
other words that people will draw back from the church now that's happened in
Ireland as well okay and even drawback from the sacraments so that their
contact may not poison them more and render them more evil isn't it frightening
my sorrow is great the wounds of my heart are deep therefore pray and united to
those few good who are left that's the remnant compassionate my bitter sorrow
so I want to give you two Corinthians six from verse 14 to chapter seven verse
one that's the same Paul telling us what we have to be prepared to put up with
to actually defend the church so to Corinthian six 14 to seven one and I want
to give you John 17 verses 15 and 16 the world hates the church wants to
destroy them and I want to give you one Kings John 17 verses 15 and 16 and I want
to give you one Kings 19 verse 18 so in one Kings 18 and 19 Elijah is
confronting the religious leaders of his day to go and make them choose the true
God so this is an area of real intercession that we need to get into and it
might be something we could even organize among us okay so September the 25th
1918 the office of the victim soul I was very afflicted Louisa said and I felt a
force in my interior of wanting to go out of my usual state she said what pain
I felt immortal I can only Jesus can know the torment of my soul and so on so
while I was swimming in this bitterness my beloved Jesus all afflicted came and
placing one of his fingers on my mouth he said I have made you content be quiet
I've done what you asked now don't give me the words I don't need them don't you
remember how many times I showed you great mortalities cities depopulated and
almost deserted World War II and definitely World War III and you told me
no don't do this but if you want to do it you must allow them to have the time
to receive the sacraments and I am doing this he said what else do you want now
this is the first time that you actually get an insight into World War I and II
that you won't get anywhere else and it's not in the history books that
Louisa interceded that if the Lord would allow these wars to happen that that she
asked him in the divine will to make sure priests got to the soldiers in the
trenches and one of our famous priests died in the trenches remember Father
Willy Doyle and going to these souls and it's it's beautiful to just see
the prayer and the answer to it and he says I've done it I've done what you
asked okay so I'm doing this he said I want to give you Luke 119 to 10 that's
the prayer without ceasing and I want to give you mark seven verses 23 to 25
you absolutely pray utterly believing and the mountain will move okay so what
else do you want he said but the heart of man is hard that's Jeremiah 17 verses
9 to 10 the heart of man is hard what's this now the heart of humanity is not
completely tired he has not touched the summit of all evils and so he's not yet
satiated and absolutely unbelievable so you would think that the atrocities of
World War I wouldn't have produced worst atrocities in World War II I can't even
imagine what they're going to do in World War III so he does not surrender and he
looks within difference even upon the epidemic we're in the middle of an
epidemic aren't we this was the Spanish flu 1918 and it killed at least 20
million people so is looking within difference even upon the epidemic but
these are the preludes as soon as beginning it will come the time will come
in which I will make this generation so malignant and perverted as to almost
disappear from the earth I hope it doesn't get any worse than it is yeah so I
want to give you Isaiah 24 verses 1 to 23 Isaiah 24 verses 1 to 23 that's an
entire nation described as having turned into a leper I want to give you Matthew
19 8 Mark 3 5 Mark 10 5 Mark 16 14 Romans 2 5 it's a good
life of scriptures look up there in a Louisa said she was shaking when she was
hearing this which was also praying and she wanted to ask Jesus what should she
do which didn't get she didn't dare and so what Jesus said is what I want now
she didn't tell Jesus in words but he can read our thoughts what I want he said
on your part is that you do not dispose yourself to doing it although being
free you can do it so what are you talking about wanting to go out of our
usual state of victim that's you see that's the first sentence of this
message and then he answers it he said don't do it because terrible
devastation will come on the earth he said I want you at the mercy of my will
in these past days it was I who pushed you to go out of your usual state I
wanted to widen the scourge of the epidemic look at that is that incredible
so even her temptation to go out of her state widen the epidemic and I did not
want to keep you in order for you to be more afraid I don't know about you I
find that absolutely unbelievable for the simple reason that there is a I call
it an epidemic going around the world I wonder has it hit any of us that in
living in the divine will we have the power in the divine will to push it back
have we taken that responsibility do we realize that yes there's a crisis in
the priesthood what do we realize that in the divine will you can push that
back I'm over pushing back is the attack of Satan so that the people can
recover because it's Satan that's bringing on the disasters so I think that in
this time before drum and team it's growing up time for us it's maturing
time that we've got to realize this incredible gift has been given to us
we've got to take it in our hands and we've got to actually use it for the
benefit of humanity because I don't want the Lord the Lord to say to me I gave
you a gift which you let them you let them suffer anyway and we have read
already today I will let you go I'll see how far you will reach do you really
want to do something and so I'm going to stop here I'm not going to go into
another message and I just want to say to you that we have to decide as a group
are we going to lock shields together Jesus said Matthew 19 18 if two of you
agree concerning any matter I will ratify it in heaven okay I'm not going to ask
you for an answer now we'll meet next week but we have to decide will we use
the power we have in the divine will to release the nation not only from the
epidemic that's threatening it but from the terrifying attack of Satan that is
brought our nation down that makes sense to you yeah so if you would give time to
thinking about that and if you could come back next week with the decision
then we can go ahead because I think we have been given such a gift that we've
got to say thanks to the Lord and the reason I'm not going into another
message is that it's just after 20 to 4 and I said I'd stop at a quarter to
okay I think this is a good point to stop is that all right and thank you for
coming